[Music]
rough night last night though for rick
santorum you all know about this right
despite losing all three primaries
yesterday
rick santorum still refusing to drop out
of the race
yeah although it shouldn't be a surprise
that the guy with seven kids isn't that
good at pulling out
[Applause]
i'm glad i don't get it uh
you know that romney and obama that
we're you know we're still in the
primaries but it feels like the general
election's already broken out they're
already exchanging barbs these two
yesterday president obama accused the
republicans of social darwinism
today mitt romney accused president
obama of rhetorical excess
when asked to comment former president
bush said what
and they gave him ice cream he's fine
i couldn't believe this speaking of
president obama recently at the white
house president obama admitted that he's
a trekkie
he said he's a trekkie yeah although
trekkies say he doesn't qualify because
he has a wife and a job
john mccain said an interesting thing
this morning john mccain was asked who
mitt romney should consider for vice
president mccain laughed and said sarah
palin
yeah when no one else laughed mccain's
side stared into the distance and said i
guess he had to be there
and he drank it
he drank his tear
and he had superpowers
you all know about the mega millions
controversy in maryland the woman who
claims she won the mega millions lottery
said she hid the ticket at the
mcdonald's where she works
yeah to keep it from ever being found
she hid the ticket inside one of their
salads
for thousands of years
starting starting today allegiant
airlines it's going to start charging 35
extra if you have carry-on bags
yeah
meanwhile jetblue is charging 35 extra
if you want a pilot who isn't insane
[Applause]
take him away
it's too much too much yeah i want the
crazy pilot too right right why not make
a long flight more interesting sure
in a recent interview madonna's manager
said that the singer would love to do a
concert in iran
see that's how it works iran you
threaten us with nuclear weapons we
threaten you with madonna
we'll send her to you
nicholas cage is in the news nicholas
cage recently has paid the irs
six million dollars of his 14 million
dollar tax bill
yeah
in the memo line of the check cage wrote
down two ghost riders down four more to
go
in new york a woman's claiming that ryan
gosling saved her from getting hit by a
taxi
yeah
then then today in new york thousands of
women were injured jumping in front of
cavs
[Applause]
where were you yeah
my legs are broken i know
he's out of town
i didn't know uh
in ohio a high school has refused to let
a student wear a shirt that says jesus
is not a homophobe
yeah but they're cool with his baseball
cap that says buddha digs fat chicks
[Applause]
i couldn't believe this dartmouth
college it's a fine institution
dartmouth college has named their
medical school after dr seuss
true story yeah because nothing's better
than hearing your doctor say you don't
have cancer on your nose you don't have
cancer on your toes
[Music]
there's no cancer in your underwear
there is no cancer anywhere
i could keep going i really could